so it's fundamentally back to the
context switching is the
poison in context switching is poison
it's the
what what is it about email that forces
context switching is it both our
psychology that
drags us in yeah right right because
it's not
i think we've seen this through a
personal a personal will or failure
lens recently like am i addicted to
email yes
uh i have bad etiquette about my email
no it's the underlying workflow
so the tool itself i will exonerate
right i think i would rather use pop3
than a fax protocol
right i think it's easier the issue is
the hyperactive hivemind workflow
so if i am now collaborating with 20 or
30 different people
with back and forth unscheduled
messaging i have to attend those
conversations
right it's like you have 30 metaphorical
ping pong tables and when the balls come
back across you have to pretty soon hit
it back
or stuff actually grinds to a halt so
it's the workflow that's the problem
it's not the tools the fact that we use
it to do all of our collaboration let's
just send messages back and forth which
means you can't be
far from checking that because if you
take a break if you batch if you try to
have better habits
it's going to slow things down
you